this is an age where disruptions are
taking place at such a rapid pace where
the company can go from leading to
bleeding at the blink of an eye it's
really about designing to be agile
designing to anticipate the unknown
almost all solutions to problems out
there have a technology base to it and
it is the CIO who has to be leading the
charge in terms of coming up with
innovative solutions the seria program
is geared towards CIOs leveraging
technology to try to change across
organizations what we want to do is to
have everyone see the CIO
not as a cost Center but as a solution
center from strategic vision
developments innovation scaling
excellence this program will make me a
better leader this program exposes CIOs
to the cutting edge tools that are
available out there for example design
thinking or behavior design do
cutting-edge frameworks concepts best
practices out there when we brainstorm
we put up an idea and whoever can shoot
down the idea first is the genius in the
room and through Design Thinking you
know really picked up some great ways to
do brainstorming better how do we get
more rapid in terms of prototyping and
testing things rather than spending six
months kind of building something only
to get the feedback after we launch it
something as simple is understanding
that we make decisions generally 95% of
the time based on emotion and instinct
it's very fundamental and will
absolutely carry a value going forward
and probably all aspects of my life it's
the all-star content from the GSB you no
doubt and then on top of it it's in
Silicon Valley in one week you really do
get to kind of capture the essence of
what it's like here one of the great
aspects of this program is that we have
time for discussions so that others who
have similar problems can learn from one
another it is a completely immersive
week and it's joyfully intense changes
that are going to take place in the
future in organizations in the
marketplace are going to be led by CIOs
I think all these skills will allow
or CEOs to sit at the table with other
c-level executives as being really
critical and driving innovation in the
company
you